I recently received a letter inviting me
to visit the Republic of Ghana and I
immediately said yes then went straight
to Google because if you're like me you
didn't learn about Ghana in mrs.
Patterson's world history class here's
what I learned
Ghana is located on the western coast of
Africa and has been home to many
different empires including the Ashanti
Kingdom which became the dominant
trading and cultural power in
sub-saharan Africa prior to colonialism
and speaking of Colonials the Portuguese
arrived in 1471 and took an immediate
interest in what would be called the
Gold Coast due to you guessed it gold
Gold also brought the Dutch Danish
British and Swedes
all of whom built forts to house their
exports of gold diamonds cocoa and
tragically millions of human beings who
were brought from all over Africa to
begin their passage to the new world by
the 19th century the British had seized
control but the Ashanti Empire would not
give up its struggle for freedom
fighting not one but four Anglo Ashanti
wars by 1945 there was growing pressure
for independence led by a man named
Kwame
nakooma who in 1957 became president of
the first black African nation to gain
freedom from colonial rule Ghana has
gone on to become one of the most
peaceful and flourishing democracies in
all of Africa with a powerful economy
that includes manufacturing mining and
tourism which brings us to 2019 dubbed
by Donna as the year of return
commemorating the 400th anniversary of
the transatlantic slave trade the year
of return invites descendants of slaves
to visit Ghana in order to explore this
somber chapter and reconnect with the
past that history has tried to erase as
part of this initiative Ghana has
welcomed many celebrities including
Aegis Elba and a guys some people with
cataracts have mistaken for eater Salva
I'm Conan O'Brien and this is my trip to
Ghana
[Applause]